the Joe Rogan experience well there's a
picture of Bert Kreischer taking his
shirt off in the dining room I know
crazy
that's some putz I've never heard of
such a thing but it was the moment that
we became legal in California Bert
stripped his shirt office are running
around stage we were doing a
end-of-the-world podcast in the green
room or in the main room in 2016 when
when Trump was elected that was a weird
night that was a weird night I remember
where I was I was at the improv that
night yeah because we're supposed to be
doing a show and it was like a UH that's
right you guys were all onstage at that
table right that's what you Sarah Tiana
it should have been the bill burr show
yeah Hilbert was on fire he was roasting
everybody
it was amazing was a nut I remember like
we were at the improv watching the
election happen and all of a sudden
everyone was going red red red and never
and someone looked at me I was like her
in trouble oh my god yeah we're totally
[ __ ] well people didn't think it was
coming they had this idea well people
have these ideas of what's good and
what's not good what's gonna happen and
not kind of which brings me back this
mayor Pete guy mm-hmm they they came up
with that guy because they said look
here he is he's a young handsome guy
he's gay he's a mayor he speaks well I
think you served as a military yeah so
like this will be the guy but he's also
backed by all these billionaires like
it's a [ __ ] it's a shell game what do
you mean he's got a wine cave leave him
alone he's got a wine key what does that
mean well didn't what's it like
Elizabeth Warren said something like he
had this fundraiser at a wine cave like
yeah I was like all these like rich
billionaires it was like a cave what is
it called a wine cellar but it happened
to be a cave somewhere out here in
California they're just trying really
hard to keep it for being Bernie really
hard
I don't want Bernie Sanders he'd get if
he gets in there apparently you know he
was an independent for so long and he
doesn't want to play ball and he doesn't
accept any money doesn't cept accept any
money just anything cool grandpa yeah I
think he's I mean [ __ ] I
I love Bernie you know why cuz he like
you could say uh happy Martin Luther
King Day that's but then you look at an
old picture of him and he's marching
next to Martin Luther King right for
civil rights yeah that's a
you can't be like no like where were you
right you know it's like I just I don't
know I I have hope I hope for somebody
just to I have hope for him socially
yeah I like I like what he stands for
socially but then you look at I don't
know if economically it's feasible
because I know I don't understand
economics like when when people start
talking about he said when he was on
here he was describing that if they just
took a very small amount of money from
every transaction that they do like less
than one cent from every transaction
that the Wall Street does that it would
add up to more than enough money to pay
for health care and a lot of other
things cool he was explaining it all and
he was explaining it like very calmly
and it didn't seem like he was
bullshitting I was out I don't think he
is a bullshitter I think he's been in
the game for years he knows how it works
he's not a [ __ ] he knows how these
people with money work you know yeah
it's something and it's just so it's
such a weird upheaval politically like
things don't make 100% sense anymore
yeah I have no I actually had a friend
of mine asked basis you know because we
got our voter registration because we
vote March 3rd here so they're like who
do you are you gonna pick him like I
don't know I mean we're gonna go blue
anyways but it's just like I honestly
don't know
it looks like Bernie Sanders is gonna be
the nominee first he's winning in New
Hampshire it looks like you are they
saying he won in Iowa no I think Pete
did he pull [ __ ] he beat him by six
thousand votes it's such a it's so but
creepy beat him in a dance-off so oh I
would love to see Pete just more coin
flips that's oh oh that's right how
about that fake coin flip they robbed
that coin whoever that is that did that
coin flip put that kid in a jail cell
what son of a [ __ ] did you see that
coin oh I want to see the coin flips
hilarious was this in Iowa
yeah hilariously rigged watch the coin
flip hold on dude from the beginning
watch this watch how bad this coin flip
is go fullscreen go fullscreen please
and do it from the beginning watch this
flips it catches it look holds it so he
can see
Wow hey [ __ ] you and no one said
anything oh they're all happy yeah it's
mayor Pete look yay that's what they
wanted they wanted to be mayor Pete so
this dude rigged this coin flip in front
of the whole world watch this pulls it
looks at it okay how shall I flip it
I'll do it like that horse [ __ ] it's not
how you do a coin flip goddamn Oh at all
Iowa learned a coin flip imagine if you
were betting $100 with that guy said
I'll bet your hundred bucks
is there okay I'll flip a coin oh I win
way mean you win you [ __ ] you rigged it
look at that hey what what what is his
jacket what is the patch what I'm a [ __ ]
mmm four thieving [ __ ] to cut four so
that's really bad I win flips I love
that woman who's like every mom in Iowa
like I'm proud of my son
how's that old guy watching right next
to me hey you [ __ ] that's not how you
flip a coin what country you're from
kind of nonsense is that
that's whole eating more of its just
people calling out [ __ ] yeah is that
from is that you do it in Greenland it's
not all you do in America you don't get
to look at the coin then flip it over to
the other side you [ __ ] okay he
looked at it and it turned it like
manipulated it with his hands like do it
again just do it again
yeah well so you do it flip that [ __ ]
let it land on the ground yeah let it
land on the [ __ ] everybody back up so
they do it football yeah and I know that
yes I mean flip that [ __ ] money on that
yeah but yet this is literally could it
could change politics like one way or
the other if Bernie gets it or if mayor
Pete gets it the delegates it all add up
to one guy or I mean I go down to the
wire I mean that's [ __ ]
creep the whole thing's [ __ ]
[ __ ] what is this what they did they
went off on this of course they did but
this is what they did to Bernie Sanders
in 2016 they rigged the DNC rigged my
Mary's then they don't want him and
they're doing it now because he's cuz
you can't he won't work with them it's
not corrupt yeah they want someone who
takes that money you don't want Tulsi
and they don't want Bernie they pushed
them out yeah right they effectively
eliminated them as threats slow but they
can't Bernie's got too much grass roots
behind him but who do you think if say
if he gets the the nominee nomination
who do you think he'll pick his vice he
picks Tulsi he'll be smart
[Applause]